[Music]
black lives matters on the surface but
what's underneath is a cry society's
agenda has been constructed to train
people to be either average or less than
average and I say you know what I'm just
gonna write it I'm not gonna try to be
perfect cuz well I'll try to be perfect
I'm not trying to be myself I'm just
gonna be myself and inside of that less
perfection people only listen to people
who they can relate to are you freaking
adjusting all over the place
loving people all over the place coming
up with solutions
dude no you know more than this the
chapters I love the little like you have
this artwork I don't know what they I
don't even what to call it it's so
different this book is a pretty easy
read I'm a slow reader but but at the
end of every chapter he's got like these
giant messages sometimes they like get
you right away like a quote but
sometimes it's like it makes you think I
mean they always make you think what you
got to think about like it's little
graphic this little cartoon yeah I love
it dude it was such a surprise on the
end of each one 300 what does this mean
is like you know all this kind of stuff
it's a refreshing tape so yeah so like
whenever I go to go to get my car wash
there's always these little books that's
inside of the store but they all have
these big old quotes on them and those
are my favorite books to look at they're
like burst of inspiration so I was like
man how can I do that so I went into
over and I literally did every single
one of them inside of a hat and that
sent it to the editing people and they
did it for me but what I didn't realize
is now people are reading it with their
five-year-olds and they're reading it
with their seven year olds and they're
gravitating towards those little pages
so now the whole family can read the
book together I like it I did a series
on my channel with Neil Fisher who sold
a million plus
books and he said one of the key things
that helped him was what he calls
breathability make sure that it's easy
to scan easy to read it's not just pure
text and and you did it man like it's
just I just like the look it's like a
little bit of candy is it going through
too and it always connects to what was
in the book or what was in the previous
chapter and I'm so excited because I'm
I'm act like I'm in and I'm reading it
right now right so I'm such a slow
reader but I like reading at least like
one chapter and so I'm about it was like
can you see I'm like halfway through
right through it but no title on the
book every time like what's his book
called again I got at least this on the
side can't your mindset change your life
yeah you know when I was working with
the artist I was like you know what I
want to have a cover that represents my
story of from when I lived in my car to
completely transform in my life that you
can just look at and you don't even have
to know what the title is because it
tells the entire journey of
transformation and then he sent me
something and then that sparked an idea
that I had we kept going back and forth
and so whenever I looked at it I went to
30 different stores two people who I
didn't know I was like when you see this
what do you think so I'm just asking
strangers and then this one girl at
urban out there she was like it reminds
me of like change and something about
like changing her life and I don't know
it's really cool it's like some from
death to life than to change and and I
was like you are there you're exactly
the confirmation I'm looking for because
it was people who didn't know me and I
just said what do you think so when I
painted title on the front it took away
from the art and I'm a visual artist and
I was like you know what I want art to
go out game they can see the title on
the back but I just want the art to be
so captivating and so that's I know
title yeah dude I love it I mean I
remember when you sent me you see me
like a graphic of it before you actually
had the book out so yes a sneak peak
before like that's such a wild cover and
and the thing that I that pulled me in I
mean
that makes sense very like the death to
the life and like the desert to the
mountains at all that open come on what
I didn't get so now I got you the gears
you got like the gears and mechanics and
like robot stuff into flowers and it's
like okay the gears this robot so when
you get caught up into society's agenda
society's agenda has been constructed to
train people to be either average or
less than average that's why they said
that though whoever designed the school
systems
it hasn't changed in you know freakin
cellphones changed every two years the
school system design hasn't changed and
there's 2% wealthy and the rest will die
trying to figure it out but they get
them when they're like little kids and
you can domesticate a child and whatever
you agreed upon as a child you'll play
out as an adult unless you wake up to
two new awarenesses and things like that
so that was just the robotic mainstream
that a lot of people are in that don't
even know that they're in because it the
cemetery's not where you see the most
dead people it's when you walk around
outside and you see a bunch of people
where something's died inside of them
because they gave up on their dream to
follow the path of whatever mainstream
media tries to control people so those
robotic gears we're just me caught up
into living a life based off of what I
thought people thought actually lived my
life it was like trying to pray up to
all the right people instead of
listening to my own gifts my own guy
giving talents is my own voice my own
intuitions because everybody hides it
inside of them but when you're trying to
follow all these different patterns you
lose yourself in the process so I felt
like a robot I felt dead I felt like
I'll be just like inside of this
monotonous thing but once I started
thinking for myself believing listening
to those voices truly honoring what's
inside of me that's when man every time
I followed and
intuition it led me to the result that I
wanted eventually so if it was difficult
when I followed the intuition it
strengthened me and cultivated me into
the kind of person that could sustain at
the next level who deserve to get the
next level I love that the get into life
change your mindset change your life you
got to go pick this one up look this up
change your mindset change your life
Garen Jones
you can't miss is coming into some name
is on right you could pick this up yeah
yeah you can get it on Amazon you won't
you won't get the custom autograph
dude your your place to like every I
mean I've had tons people on my IT lives
and your your places every room in your
place yeah why the hell you want to see
the whole thing have you seen the whole
thing last time but like I'm sure
there's some new stuff I remember this
room and then you got the water on the
ceiling or something so this room is the
inspiration room and these are example
who have inspired me
yeah what Connor you guys freaking Jesus
yeah I McGregor's next to Jesus right
Smith down there not John see Maxwell
the Teresa mother Teresa John see
Maxwell Gandhi why what you got Muhammad
Ali in there quotes you know what I'm
saying yeah you got Oh bro you guys my
[ __ ] King
darkness cannot drive out darkness only
light can do that yeah hate cannot drive
out hate only love can do that so this
is one room then I have a room that is
cold this is in Rome oh this one there's
like grass on the floor that's awesome
dude somebody said where's Michael
Jordan Michael Jordan we didn't motivate
me to change my life I was inspired by
his play
there's nothing that he said motivated
me to change my life
so only put people there that so this is
outside being the guy in the backyard
yes and we had this is the acclamation
room so there's affirmations all over
the wall ah and so you know I stand in
love I choose to stand in love no matter
what just coming at me so that's my
wife's telethon and there's my bike
right next to it nice so all of that in
there and because we love taking backs
got a big huge [ __ ] box right there
nice and then and how do I one second
this is my favorite room this is the sky
room so there is clouds and there's
water right there
yeah most there's mocha Jesus it's like
a 3d version yeah all over the wall and
that's the view outside did you did you
make these or you're clogging with an
artist or like so basically when I was
homeless living in my car sleeping in an
abandoned building sleeping in my
storage unit 8 and a half years ago I
heard someone say you know you shouldn't
do a vision board you should do a vision
environment like so you go to your house
and then you put a picture of your dream
house inside of your house you go into
your it whatever kind of car you drive
into you put a picture of your car
inside of your dream car inside of your
car so in everywhere where I was staying
what I did could see when you have a
vision board you have borders on it but
when you create a vision and BIOS that
no borders oh snap
you hear them saying so so what happened
was when I was
in my storage unit I had a photo that I
drew of my dream house of what I wanted
what the rooms were gonna look like how
there was gonna what they were all gonna
have it carry a different frequency and
energy but this is while I was living in
my car and living in my storage unit so
each room it just carries a different
energy so whenever I want to be in a
specific energy when I'm you know want
to charge myself up with a bunch of
affirmations I'll say everything on the
wall you know this there's the
inspiration room they say you are the
five closest people you hang out with
but they didn't say they have to be
alive yes so or they have to be in bed
to be physically in your presence so if
I keep seeing them I'm reminded of all
the impact that they've made in the
world moving sorry well that came from
that came from a painting that I saw but
that painting that I saw when I was in
second grade
someone had this all this adult tried to
drown me in this river and as I was
being like I heard about all these
different people I mean all these kids
that were dying in the neighborhood in
Missouri City they were being drowned by
these adults I didn't I didn't know who
they were so one day I was playing
baseball and and I was in second grade
and these guys that were my cousin's
friends and I knew them that's like oh
there's some fish in the bio or whatever
and I was a big fisherman so I went to
the Bayou and everybody was telling you
don't go don't go and then they're
saying you got to look closer and as
soon as he said you got to look closer
that's when I put it together then these
are the kid these are the guys that are
drowning all the kids and they threw me
into the river and then I was getting
sucked up into a tunnel anything that
goes into the tunnel is gonna die
I got sucked up and I got flipped upside
down because of a whirlpool so I'm in
the water getting sucked into the tunnel
already underwater a hand reaches in the
water pulls me out just enough for me to
come out I look up and I see no one and
all my life I was like who was that hand
and I never saw anyone when I saw that
painting of the Jesus reaching through
the water I was like oh my god
that's what I want on to sit on the
ceiling so yeah how that came about
that's why and that's your bedroom right
yeah that's what you wake up to every
day that's why I'm yeah okay so you get
that idea then what like did you paint
that yourself are you higher so far I
know it's so there was a there was a
person that just comment on stuff on my
Instagram and there's a guy named Chad
and then all of a sudden I didn't know
he was an artist
I just always anybody who comments or
anything I just go on their page I went
on this page and I saw all of this crazy
work I didn't know him but I reached out
and I said how would you like to fly to
LA just not pay stay at my house and
paint a mural of MOCA Jesus on my on my
ceiling he was like oh my god I'm such a
fan and I was crazy but you know what's
awesome is he said this is the first
time in my life anybody's ever believed
in me like this and since then he's
blown up so big it was the Butte most
beautiful thing that has happened so
that's what's up man hold on
so we got the staircase that has you
know the book and then you have you are
powerful right there nice this was at me
and my wife's wedding nice that was a
fire dancer they took an artwork change
your mindset change your life this is
our kitchen and how do I take it
these stairs here go out of the way up
go all the way up to the backyard and
then this is like a little resting area
here oh man
but then there's like a daybed there's
my wife in there I wrote it all I wrote
it all over listen I could write a book
on the process that it took for me to
write that book because I tried every
way possible I tried to hire a
ghostwriter I was like man I I don't
even believe this cuz it don't sound
like my words I hired a developmental
editor I tried this I tried then I was
like man I'm gonna write myself yeah
sounds like your lives
yeah when it came to my book I just like
the hardest part was trying to you know
I have to be this way I have to be I
gotta sound like an author yeah I got a
sound like this and I was like now what
do people really like about the message
that I share cuz I don't give it like
I'm so wrong with it and I say you know
what I'm gonna write a book that feels
like somebody has a friend that
somebody's like you've got somebody
that's like right there and I just when
I got clean on that it took me a week it
took me five years to write the perfect
book but then once I got clear it's like
I'm just gonna get the information now
and I want it to sound exactly how I
talk who I'm trying to reach like I
wasn't trying to reach Tony Robbins I'm
trying to reach the people who don't
usually write books so I need to write
it in a way that's really simple and and
and it's so many people who've never
read books before they're like man your
book was the first book I ever read
thank you so much
you're the person who I was trying to
reach but if anybody else relates to it
that's what happens but that whenever I
just really buckled in I say you know
what I'm just gonna write it I'm not
gonna try to be perfect because well I'm
trying to be perfect I'm not trying to
be myself I'm just gonna be myself and
inside of that was perfection yeah
nice dude I love it well it's a great
reach guys go pick it up look up look
that's how you spell it
Garen Jones go look it up change your
minds to change your life um hey before
we pop off any any quick message for
what's going on now like how you're
dealing with it you know it's and you
can't you can't you can never understand
what it's like living inside of a black
of a black person's body and
experiencing what the experience so you
can only know from my perspective
because everybody can look at the same
thing and see something totally
different but for me someone who's
experienced racism still to this day
literally my entire life and some I was
like whoa you're massively successful I
was like but I'm still experienced it's
like the undertones of it you know for
me it's about bringing awareness I don't
take a lot of things personal because
I've done a lot of work I've done
frickin master's in spiritual psychology
freakin deep soul hard at work ten day
silent retreats all kind of things most
people don't have that so only people
people only know how to express
themselves in a way that's that's normal
to them so when you take a society and
then you suppress them for 400 years and
then say you're free there's actually
not freedom in that if they don't have a
concept of freedom and there's no that
the the culture was never reformed so we
got to find a way to express ourselves
through music through fashions do all
these different things and on the other
side is people say oh no it's all lives
matter
all lives matter but you gotta
understand black people have never been
a part of the conversation from the
context of dignity and it in a systemic
way which is why all the black people so
maybe like people are in in in prisons
and all these different things but monk
so many people that I know won't look at
them it's like they have this one
narrative and there's like but why is
everybody so screaming and so this is my
take on everything
imagine a baby if anybody knows how try
it children work that's saying mom mom
mom mom they're trying to get your
attention
mom mom mom and then the parent not
acknowledging the child's cries
eventually that child's cries is going
to turn to rage and anger and if you
keep ignoring that child there would be
from emotional content standpoint they
wouldn't even they want they wouldn't be
able to resonate with the mom or dad
because the mom or dad was never open to
the to the to the conversation or
whatever it was that the child is trying
to say but if you really want to hear
what's underneath black lives matter
because it's up black lives matters on
the surface but what's underneath is a
cry and so to deny someone a voice like
Lily to deny someone the ability to
express themselves when culturally it's
always been shut down is like the little
kids going mom mom mom mom mom and at
the end of the day people want to feel
seen heard and knowledge and they want
to feel like they're matter they matter
so what you think is freedom is actually
not freedom because you can't be truly
free until you have the power to possess
your own mind but when it's never been
restored and never been you know if
you've never been supported in that way
to understand how to possess your own
mind then you'll constantly
recreate the same patterns over and over
and over and over and over so my take on
what's going on is there's a cry to be
seen and then there is not acknowledge
those who are actually saying we do
matter it's been there's a lot of
dismissiveness is going on it's very
interesting because a lot of my friends
or I really don't know didn't like man
I'm all about humanity I'm all about
just like I want to stand for people and
I've seen them passionately stand stand
for gay rights
I've seen them passionately stand for
women's rights and when it came to the
oppression of black people they've been
silent I'm like wait was where is you
know I'm your friend and this is
something that I'm I've been going
through my whole life so for you to say
nothing the question is it was like what
I don't know what to say I was like well
you didn't know anything about the gun
rights either but you did your research
and you stayed for the people all I'm
saying is if you're really about the
people then stand for all people if you
want all lives to matter black lights
have to be a part of the conversation so
if that's not a part of the conversation
then you really gotta check in with
yourself and be like what's that about
and I'm gonna leave you with this and I
shared this with all with all the time
because one of one of my white friends
he goes well then how it's my words
gonna make a difference and I said I'm
gonna tell you exactly how so when I was
five years old I was on the playground
and and these five white boys that I was
living in Arkansas at that time so it
was crazy
and I'm 40 I'll be 41 in a couple of
weeks when I was five years old five
white boys were chasing me on the
playground every single day and beating
me up and calling me [ __ ]
all the time and I would just get so I
say stop stop stop leave me alone right
but then this one white boy
says stop leave him alone he didn't do
anything to you and they stopped so my
friend my white friend pint Gate says
how can anything that I do make a
difference and when I shared with him
when I was being chased by five white
boys who are trying to pour demeaning me
disrespecting me
people only listen to people who they
can relate to so because the white boy
stood up for the black boy the white
boys listen to the other white boy and
they stopped and they never chased me
again they left me alone and I've knows
all these different things when I share
that with my friend they were like wow I
didn't realize I had that much power I
was like yes you were born with
privilege I was like you were born with
privilege there's things that you'll
never have to experience that I've
experienced my entire life
so with that privilege you can actually
do something with it so your voice
matters so when you say hey black lives
do matter they listen to you more than
they listen to me because I'm just
another black person screaming out
something but when it's you saying it
now people who look like you who have
the same difference same pigmentation
they're like oh well maybe I should
listen and I'm watching that happen so
that's my takes you know that's my take
on everything going on me I know I know
but I'm not gonna be screaming all lives
matters you know if we're in a forest
and a tree is burning I'm not gonna be
all the trees matter no I'm gonna focus
on the tree that's freaking burning so
it doesn't spread over all the other
trees so that's my take I'm just sending
love and being a solution oriented
person and educating people who actually
really want to know and for anybody out
there you don't have to kill that deep
sense of guilt is
whatever you just got to figure that out
and we frame how you look at yourself
but don't feel guilt to Bend stand for
black lives if it's not really in your
heart to do it because we don't want any
handouts either we just want our just do
first stuff that we've worked really
hard for and things like that
and I want us to all live in this world
all be United and everything but
everybody must get the same opportunity
oh man well I mean preaching cheryan and
you see the world differently right I
mean you experience it differently you
see it differently and that it shows and
like your design and your tour and all
that and it's awesome to see you know
the voice from love and the way that you
can express it can hit people in a way
that I don't think other people will be
able to hear so I'm you know I
appreciate you gonna be a force for good
and coming on and sharing with my mic my
tribe as well hopefully just a little
more context to what's going on man
you're so welcome and thank you for
everything that you do on a daily basis
providing education awareness just
around transformation everything thank
you for even I was a fan of yours and
when you first reached out to me I don't
even know who you were because you're
like hey I want you to come on my top
ten and I didn't even know you were
talking about and then when I looked up
your name I was like how you put me
featured me on your top ten on YouTube
that's really cool because that was the
start of me coming public with just like
me wanting to be a global voice for
humanity so thank you for your platform
because it allows people like me to have
my story shared for the for the people
who've never know knew that it was
possible to make more of their life full
men appreciate you listen one last
question in the in the comments one word
that that's that's my first book so your
most important core value they want to
know what is mr. Jones's most
core value in one word love love
frequency in the world
it oozes from everything you do man hey
thanks thanks for popping on pre shake
you and everything you're doing man
can't I can't wait to see you know this
blow up but but everything else are you
doing is just it's awesome n if you want
to see the other one on one I did with
Garen Jones check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there